comet pizza a popular Washington DC
neighborhood restaurant unwittingly at
the center of a deeply troubling
internet storm last weekend as people
were dining inside here a 28 year old
man turned up armed with an assault
rifle - as he puts it self investigate
what police have called a fictitious
online conspiracy theory the man fired a
shot inside the restaurant no one was
hurt but this became an alarming
consequence of a growing online
phenomena fake news so I think we're
definitely on to something here with
this pizza gate investigation this
stemmed from a bizarre and completely
false article claiming that Hillary
Clinton was running a child sex ring out
of the pizzeria one of the more
high-profile figures fanning the flames
of the spurious story was Michael G
Flynn the son of retired General Michael
T Flynn who president-elect Donald Trump
has tapped to be his national security
adviser after the attack Flynn jr.
tweeted that the story had not been
proved untrue following this tweet he's
no longer working for Trump's transition
team but the president-elect swore on
the establishment has created a climate
for such theories that could come back
to haunt him he has loosed onto the
scene a an openness to volatile and
exotic ideas and it will be interesting
to see how he tries to rein that in when
he needs people to believe him other
businesses like the politics and prose
bookstore on the same block as comic
pizza have been tied to the false report
staff here have been receiving
threatening phone calls
they came from untraceable numbers and
people just sort of talking about saying
you know they knew what was going on and
they were gonna come and they were going
to do terrible things sort of making
these wild - coming up with these wild
theories about underground tunnels
linking our businesses and and much much
worse all of the affected businesses
have been comforted by the Solidarity
shown by their customers
but after Sunday's shooting incidents
there now watching more closely who
comes through their doors the area now
has police protection as long as these
lies dressed as fact can be disseminated
freely on the Internet
there's an unsettling sense that this
could happen again with more devastating
consequences Amanda Walker's Sky News
Washington